- All right everybody
let's close up this hour
with something truly uplifting.
This is "What I'm Liking."
(upbeat music)
(audience applauding)
You may remember just a few weeks ago,
we had the Oscar winning
cast of the film 'CODA' here,
it was amazing.
They've helped shine an important light
on the deaf community,
not just their challenges but
simply their everyday life.
As Deaf History Month continues,
I wanna introduce you to another
actress bringing attention
to those who are deaf or hard of hearing.
You've seen her in the
movies 'Wonderstruck',
'A Quiet Place' and 'The Sequel',
and she signed in the
ASL version of my video
for 'I Dare You'.
It was really magical.
Now she's just released a
necklace to help encourage people
to learn American sign language.
Here we go.
Let's say hi to Millie
Simmons and her mama Emily.
(audience applauding)
Hello.
So it's so great to meet you.
So you lost your hearing
in two months old.
But doctors told your mom
not to teach you ASL. Why?
- That's right.
The audiologist told my mom
that if she learned to ASL,
I would never learn to speak.
Though I was very lucky
that she didn't listen.
Went ahead and learned sign language.
And also I went to a deaf school.
I grew up going to a deaf school
and I noticed that some
kids that I was with
didn't want to go back home,
and I didn't really understand why.
And then it wasn't until later in life
that I realized they're hearing...
their parents really didn't learn
how to communicate with them at home.
Only 10% of hearing parents really learn.
And I was shocked to learn that.
So I feel like it's really important
to highlight this issue.
- Emily, do you wanna tell
us about this necklace?
This is a really cool idea.
What does this exactly mean?
- Yes. The necklace is the sign for mom.
And so it has the profile.
And then the hand if it goes on the chin,
that is the sign for a mom.
And we wanted unlike the 'I love you' sign
that you see everywhere.
We wanted it to kind of
focus and be specific to ASL,
and kind of highlight the
relationship that you can have
when deaf kids have
access to their language.
So...
- Everybody
(audience applauding)
to pick up the Millie ASL Mama necklace
and support the Sky High Institute,
go to cutandclarity.co.
Thank you so much Millie and Emily.
Thank you.
(audience applauding)
I'm liking your post right now.
All right that's not although
our season long partner
Pilot Pen Makers of Friction
go to erasable pin of
the Kelly Clarkson Show
wanna celebrate those creating fearlessly,
just like y'all.
So they're gonna give
you a thousand dollars.
How's that sound.
(audience applauding)
(host laughs)